all right we have reached the end of the
hour but let's squeeze in one more great
story this is what I'm
[Applause]
liking the father daughter dance is a
highlight at most weddings in California
a bride and her dad used old video to
make the moment even more touching take
a
[Music]
look
oh man so sweet the wedding was two
years ago but the bride recently posted
it as a tribute to her dad on his
birthday and it took off from there
because it's the sweetest thing ever
let's get them in here say hi to ran and
Andy watching on NBC Los
Angeles hi hi oh my gosh so whose idea
was it to do the video behind y'all
dancing we would love to take credit for
it but it was 100% my mom's idea long
before I ever got engaged or had met my
husband even she was like when you get
married I'm going to have that
fatherdaughter dance playing the video
of you guys when you were little and
she's an event planner so she kind of
sored it away in the back of her mind
and so when the time came we dug out the
video and we kind of put it together we
kept it as a surprise from all of our
guests so that night was just so full of
emotion we were obviously emotional and
crying the whole time and really just
the whole room was crying with us so she
took a really special memory and made it
so much more special yeah if anyone
wasn't crying they have no soul like
that was so beautiful like and it's
especially to shock people that like
they don't know it's coming oh my gosh
so Andy do you remember making the video
the F the video the first time well
right now Kelly we are actually in the
room that we made the video oh y'all
like a country song okay this is like
this has been our this has been our
house for the last 40 years and every
time I walk in this room uh I remember
making that video yeah it was a very
special evening I was on my way uh
overseas for a week and we really had no
videos of of Rihanna and I and my wife
says we got to put something on film we
got to get something so G uh Gaston was
playing so we picked up and I was
twirling around the room to the Gaston
video first and then my wife she fast
forward it to tell as old as time and
as soon as that came on Ranon slapped
her head right against mine like this
and we we went into this magical moment
of a dance that I'll never forget as
long as I
live
okay that like I wasn't even at the
wedding and I'm like crying that is so
you're like the greatest dad oh my God
and your wife and your mom is so cool
everybody I'm good okay thank you thank
you so much Reena for sharing that video
thank you Andy for joining us that was
so super special I'm liking your post
right now
right thank you thank you thank you Kell
and that's not all actually our season
long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to celebrate
amazing families just like yours I'm
still trying not to cry so they're going
to give you
$1,000 oh y'all got me okay thank you
you guys so much your beautiful family
thank you to all our guests this hour me
Ryan davidy cat Graham Lou Sophia and
Daniel you have a great thing if it's
not TR
[Music]
[Applause]
changing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home what